[Music]
wait wait
um jack holler uh the baby lil wayne
your music
tiffany is not trash quite the opposite
actually
mine miners apparently according to this
friendly soul that commented on my last
seeing sounds
dan your music is trash
you weirdo therefore i was like why
don't i take my favorite
current artist's new track what's
and recreate it out of the
trash found in my office trash can yes
there will be a lot of weird shits
found in here that's because i'm a
weirdo
what's evie
the melody of the track goes something
like this
essentially remixing an already remixed
track out of whatever i find
the here are these
recycled
we'll get there one day recycle
one fling it's gonna be a good sign sir
we'll save it
this is a tattoo needle i threw it away
because
it opened up when doing hand poked
tattoos
sanity is highly important that's why it
was wrapped with sanity
sanity sanity is important though
sanitary is highly important that's why
even though the needle was just a little
bit out it was wrapped in
these gloves so they didn't poke anyone
this brew will make a very interesting
sound along with a new type of base
oh really thought that was going to give
us base
recycled how's this clapper
ready
[Music]
let's see if i can salvage this graphic
tape
and stick these guys together
but slowly cutting the shorter the pitch
will get higher which will give us a
variety
within the baseline so i'm going to chop
it when making the track a very
old cell phone to be recycled i'm
convinced this would make this
by this i'm sure you've recognized my
coke addiction
coke er cola obviously for anyone who
was thinking
something else something outrageous
[Music]
so
[Music]
my trash can hold your [ __ ] you mean it
no options i can make the speed with
feeling
not joking i can make a track out of
anything my body got rid of them bottles
clean clean
[Music]
my trash can hold you [ __ ] you mean it
no options i can make this beat with
feeling
not joking i can make a track out of
anything my body got better than bottles
[Music]
i'm okay okay that was
totally pointless and talking of
pointless these new
mud roll ads that just come in and
completely destroy
the drop of the track that's why i'm
keeping these seeing sounds ad
free therefore share it with your family
your buddy
the freaking country and uh don't forget
to
subscribe billy that didn't work uh
turn on your subscribe ability i think
works better
regardless of the the fail there at the
end it was a hell of a lot of fun
thank you so much for the comments i i
literally don't know which ones are
actually just
calling me out for being a complete
idiot or which which ones are
challenging me to make music but
i'm using it to fuel my creativity and
be able to make tracks out of
things like trash keep the comments
coming and speaking of comments
there's brew merch on the way it's
coming soon so
i'm gonna pick 10 people out of the
first thousand comments to get a free
oh i could have rhymed free with the
subscriber lee thing
oh to get a free hoodie
but i'm not wearing the hoodie right now
this is the long sleeve if you want a
long sleeve instead of the hoodie let me
know
other than that don't forget you're
awesome brew and
i'll see you next week